美丽的太太
你知道心脏病
最可怕的地方是什么吗
我知道
很快就会让你没命
没错马上教你
1个穴位
让你在心脏不舒服
喘不过气的时候
马上救了自己
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
六千人心肌梗塞猝死
1穴位快速自救
台湾每年有超过六千人
因为急性的心肌梗塞而猝死
心脏不舒服如何自救
我要和你分享
一个好用的急救穴
就是极泉穴
它专门帮助你
缓解心悸心跳过快
极泉穴在腋窝的中间
你用手指掐着极泉穴
然后另外一只手按着胸大肌
这样子用力拉扯一下
感觉到微微的疼痛
那就行了
按压极泉穴
可以让血液
快速流回心脏
降低心脏的压力
稳定血压
甚至你在
危急的时刻
像胸闷心脏乱跳
甚至身边有人
昏迷的状况
都可以靠这一招
救自己一命
当然也可以救其他人一命
非常实用
这样我要赶快学起来
对好
心肌梗塞爱找4种人
1动作测血管弹性
你知道吗
台湾十大死因排行榜里
心肌梗塞就是第二名
这么恐怖喔
是喔
我们来看什么人
容易得心肌梗塞
这四种人
第一种五六十岁的人
第二种有三高或者三高家族史的人
第三种生活作息差的人
像是抽烟过劳长期失眠
这些高危险群
第四种感染或者发炎
天气温差大
也容易诱发心肌梗塞
那心肌梗塞
可以自我检测吗
可以检测你的
血管的弹性和循环的状况
看血管健康或不健康
来你先把拳头
握紧几秒钟
再立即放开
观察手掌颜色
恢复的速度是怎么样
如果在三秒之内
能够恢复原本的肤色
恭喜你血管弹性还不错
但是如果恢复时间要蛮长的
表示血管可能比较硬
弹性比较差
容易有动脉硬化
或者是循环不良的风险
回家马上洗澡NG
3招抗寒护心法
天气一冷你知道吗
血管会收缩
血压就可能瞬间爬升高
心脏病急性中风的风险
也就跟着增加了
我教你三招抗寒的方法
赶快学起来
第一招回家不要直接进浴室
为什么
洗热水澡会让身体
温度瞬间剧烈的变化
血管扩张
对心血管不好的人
是很危险的
那我们先喝一杯温水
让身体暖起来吗
很聪明
喝热水以后
再开启浴室的暖气
再放热水等浴室温暖了
你再进去洗澡
那冬天泡澡
有没有什么要注意的
泡澡时间
不要超过十分钟
泡太久容易头晕
就容易摔倒很危险
第二招洗完澡后马上保暖
你洗完澡离开浴室
如果遇到冷空气
血管收缩可能诱发
心肌梗塞或中风
有人洗完澡走出浴室
踩到冰的地板上
结果头痛
右半身手脚没力了
口齿不清了
紧急送医已经脑中风
这么严重喔
那洗完澡一定要
赶快把衣服穿好
对一定要注意
第三招床边放好保暖衣物
半夜起床上厕所
或早上起床的时候
先活动活动手脚暖身
再慢慢下床
把衣物放在枕头边
或者伸手可以马上拿得到的地方
随时可用保暖又安心
接下来进一段广告
四百天的等待
只为这一口精
华玉泰 白酱油
屏东老店七十年传承
日本全湿式工法
坚持长期发酵四百天
让豆麦酱香更温润甘醇
酱油
选原味才对味
白酱油原料单纯
黄豆小麦食盐
砂糖米
无添加防腐剂香料色素
天然安心
只取第一道琥珀色原汁
通过多项认证品质有保障
玉泰白酱油最适合提鲜料理
不死咸
才吃得出真正美味
生鱼片或水饺
沾白酱油最能衬托
清爽鲜美
卤肉用白酱油软化肉质
吃起来入口即化
酱香满溢
沾煮卤百搭
凉拌豆腐
烫青菜
加一点味道立刻升级
玉泰白酱油
以传统酱油的纯粹美好
唤醒你记忆里家的味道
睡太少睡不好都伤心
心肌梗塞提高1.69倍
你昨天晚上睡得好吗
睡不好睡太少
心脏可能就会
可以给你罢工了
睡太少的人注意喔
研究显示
每天晚上
睡不到5小时的人
发生心肌梗塞风险比较
睡7到8小时的人
高那么1.56倍
1倍半以上喔
失眠的人
甚至于高出1.69倍
哇1.7倍了左右喔
来总是睡不好的人
你在睡前按一个穴位
它就是神门穴
在手腕横纹上
小指跟无名指之间
这条线的连结线上面
你左右手各按一两分钟
帮助你安定心神
更快速睡好
我要睡着啰
你以为年轻人
狂熬夜就不会出事吗
有一位大学生
他有高血压糖尿病的倾向
偏偏很爱熬夜打游戏
暑假更是玩得没日没夜的
饮食是乱七八糟
结果才20多岁
竟然就中风了
这个故事可不是个案喔
好睡眠
才是心脏最好的保养品
那我们睡得越多
是不是越好啊
这事情不是
傻人所想的那么简单
不是睡越多越好
每晚睡6个小时的人
心肌梗塞风险
比睡9小时以上的人
还要低耶
黑木耳加2物
远离中风心肌梗塞
想让血液顺畅
预防中风和心肌梗塞吗
我给你推荐一道
又好喝又能护心的饮料
木耳红枣老姜露
本草纲目记载
黑木耳活血止血
它可以抑制血小板的凝聚
预防动脉的硬化
红枣它里面含有
cAMP
它可以扩张冠状血管
改善心肌的营养
增强收缩力
预防心肌梗塞
和心脏的衰弱
再加上老姜活血醒血
整个血管就通起来了
很顺畅的
那么心脏就更健康
各位这碗木耳红枣老姜露的
详细材料和做法
我会放在最后
你今晚把它截图起来
明天就来煮煮看
3款饮料最伤心
心血管风险暴增42%
你经常爱喝饮料吗
果汁含糖饮料酒
这三种饮料喝多了
不但伤心而且还伤血管喔
我们先说果汁
我建议你喝果汁
不如吃水果
想想看
你平常一次会吃掉
三四颗柳丁吗
不会啊
不会对吧
一杯果汁是用
好多颗柳丁榨出来的
糖份很高啊
美国研究指出
每天喝高糖的果汁
一杯以上的人
得到心血管疾病风险
竟然是比不喝的人
高42%
第2个含糖饮料
你每周要喝
三次以上的含糖饮料吗
珍奶汽水提神饮料咖啡冰沙
会得到什么呢
小编说
会得到开心啊
当然会开心啊
可是喝多了
身体就不开心了
糖份过量会让
血糖剧烈的波动
体重就增加了
欧洲研究发现
每天喝两杯以上
汽水的人你知道吗
死亡风险比一个月
不到一杯的人
要高17%
心血管疾病死亡率高52%
这些糖份会让
三酸甘油脂升高
也就是中性脂肪升高
血管负担就加重了
长期下去
心脏就超累的
第3个饮料酒类
你晚上爱喝红酒或烈酒吗
长期喝酒会麻痹身体
对心脏可是个大敌啊
能造成高血压中风酒精性心肌病
心律不整的人
还可能心悸加剧
我年轻的时候
也爱喝竹叶青烈酒
入睡很快
但是呢
假如中间忽然的醒来的话
就翻来覆去
我跟你讲就再也睡不着了
长期下来
对心血管一点好处都没有
这三种饮料
真的是少喝为妙
木耳红枣老姜露做法
新鲜黑木耳1-2朵
老姜6片
红枣15个
水1200cc
红枣用刀划两刀
将黑木耳老姜所有的材料
放入电锅内锅
加入水1200cc
在电锅的外锅
加1杯半的水
按下开关烹煮
等开关跳起
后就 可以直接享用
或是取出姜片
把锅内的食材
放入果汁机中
打成稠稠的口感
就可以喝
想吃甜一点的人
可以加入适量的糖即可
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同我推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱喔
或成为VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你哦